[Music]
cool so today's test is more or less a
bunch of fitness freaks yes you guys are
all fitness freaks kind of what do you
consider a fitness freak you review the
comedian when your brand is more or less
like working out no is that my breath
you're wearing your [ __ ] Brown with
you talking about well I thought about
like a personal brand like an Instagram
brand or persona brand I'll bring you
talk about company brands why are you
making it so difficult just say yes and
go you're not like Fitness is it not
part if you don't be like comedy comedy
is a comedian the right name joke here
is he's of music I'm not a but I do
write goodness I do like fitness but
it's yeah if you had a multi-dimensional
Tacey aspect of you if you had to throw
away the comedy side or the fitness side
which one would you throw away first say
one more time if you have to throw away
the comedy side or the fitness side
which side would you throw [ __ ] that's
impossible you can't do that oh hey for
you yeah that's like sailing what do you
want to keep giving your balls no you
didn't funny my whole life but you start
working out you're like this is power
yeah give this up like I've been funny
for a while like I could dip the balls
together
you can't have one or the other that's
it for him he would get rid of the
comedy and he would keep the fitness
gotcha well here is a product that is
both comedy and fitness what at the same
time and it's called price bra why is
that comedy what part of it is notice
okay I see one of those but a dildo
attached to the chin dick yeah so you
can eat [ __ ] out of [ __ ] no I'm gonna
need a little gonna need a link to it
though so this profit [ __ ] eating
cheese cheese's right dad likes a mooing
[ __ ] hmm seems like it see where we get
the mumps oh yeah I can see that looks
pretty ridiculous we have a toothache
back in like the [ __ ] just die a face
brought round it
okay fitness guru but this is the
opposite of fitness is it yes well
they're selling it as a as a like a fat
reducer of the face how what do you call
it like the the corset training but for
the net yes like where's that training
so like the idea behind buying [ __ ] is
called strangulation yeah the horn of
course the course corset training or the
waist training it's like moving your
[ __ ] organs and it's shifting your
body you know what I mean
how would it the focus I guess it's
binding so yeah yeah it's and it's not
as like malleable but you're gonna
double chin but like how does that I
don't know about how effective it is I
think they're using the same logic as
binding yeah in order to the the example
they bring up is kind of like if you do
like plastic surgery or whatever they
give you a brace to like hold your [ __ ]
together while it's healing so it's like
braces yeah but that means you need to
get surgery for it to be held together
it's the compression though they're
saying the pressure of it how tight it
is is supposed to like help tuck away
that the flabbiness I mean what are they
trying to do they're trying to get rid
of their double chin yeah is that what
the purpose is they're trying to get rid
of the double chin yes for the double
chin oh I thought it was to have a
strong jawline
well no that's the same thing though if
you have a double chin don't you not
have as strong of a jawline cuz it's
kind of like all right cuz the saggy
part it covers up your jawline so if you
get it tucked in second half and your
jaw comes up we all have a 6-pack
underneath yes actually that's true so
we all have a jawline underneath yeah
not entirely true there is the Assembly
were like no chin
they look like Gumby old reference hello
old though but so they're marketing the
face bra as something that you don't
need a workout you don't need to diet
and just wear this thing for 40 minutes
at a time at home and you'll take
centimeters off your centimeters yeah
you're I would you call this a double
chin I was like it takes centimeters
laughter ja ah man you eat all the
french fries in the world that she's not
gonna help you that chick was eating
cheese's but she was eating it with
resistance yeah maybe the bands for your
dog Valerie it's like Jazzercise but
Johnson is like it's like a piece of
rubber or something you want to like
strengthen your jaw my god kind of gummy
you know it's like taking a ball and
then they have two bite marks on the top
and bottom so you put it in a dish so
it's like a push-pull thing jobs your
size should be like a weight though
doesn't it just get you that jawline oh
because there's a lot of skinny dude
yeah but then you got to work out you
gotta have districts wait and work out
hard man it's dumb to do when you could
just do this I'm saying they're just
skinny guys out there that have won and
they didn't do anything that's true [ __ ]
those people
yeah just kidding and then they get a
six-pack they have a six-pack
cuz they're skinny and then they get a
chick talk yep cuz like that's the look
the skinny tick-tock guy with a nice job
and they start selling programs yeah on
tick tock uh I got called out but yeah
so this thing reminded me of like the
the waist yeah I do ever seen a waist
trimmer I love those it's just you
tighten that [ __ ] up
yeah and then just like the compression
like sucks everything in for some time
until it comes back out exactly so like
what
does that do gives you so it gives you
the illusion of like being bussed here
and then being wider in the butt well no
I know like physically I mean like what
does it end up like what's the long legs
is it like compression where your organs
and [ __ ] yeah ever go guys I think they
do go back after certain amount of time
but yeah like it just messes up your all
your internal organs cuz everything's
just shifting so that it can fit in this
small space that you're always binding
does it [ __ ] up your ribs not that I
read cuz your ribs you can kind of like
move it like your ribs aren't like like
they're kind of soft I just I feel like
mine are like you could see maybe four
girls cuz you got the babies well now
they move they're not like like I mean
they kind of move around they kind of
move around they move more out than not
doing the compression like the ones I go
up they do make your everything kind of
go in and I kind of stay there for a bit
of course that one's so as you back her
they wouldn't have the one that they
[ __ ] pull like a string and Torian
yeah it makes your kiddies look good
they look like hourglasses like real one
up here and you're like you rest your
head on and then you can leave your
cheez-its there while you [ __ ] be
playing a game you get a double chin eat
off your tits yeah
the advantage it does make me feel sad
when like there's products like this
that exists because I know there are
people that want to achieve it but then
they don't have the right information
they don't know how to take the first
steps because my mom would probably
someone to buy some showing dislike sure
but isn't it funny that they do it you
can laugh at them
no cuz I know what they're really trying
to get at and I want to help them but it
looks so funny but they rather did so my
mom has this thing it's like a lot of
Asian parents have it it's like a this
vibrating machine with a yeah and then
just do it just like like everyday just
watching TV and this thing just like
vibrating shakes her fat it's supposed
to shake the fat off and as a kid I
thought I work cuz you don't you don't
know anything and then later on when I
got older I'm like dad my mom really was
self-conscious about her body but she
just wasn't informed enough to go
jogging and then they just waste time
and something that won't work and then
defeated and won't try anything else
yeah like I get it for our parents time
cuz knowledge wasn't as like available
as it is now and [ __ ] has an advanced as
much as it has now like knowledge like
now that I feel like there's no excuse
though but they're looking for an excuse
yeah but you were stolen I don't want
shortcuts and I feel like that's kind of
like what they're that's why I laugh at
them cuz it's funny I like that looks
laugh yeah let's go to the park and then
we'll see them I've not seen anyone
wearing this yet no I wouldn't wear this
in public that's for sure I mean if I
had one I'm not doing this at home in my
own privacy yeah I'm gonna own it bring
it to the gym you like you know you
girls take the waist trainer waist
trainer yeah those workout with the
waist trainer yeah but those look like
sweat it's not really the trainer those
are more for sweat like you what's a
waist trainer like the corset concept
okay so what's the one that you just
sweat and it's just what's that supposed
to do well I guess it's via targets the
fat I think so right so I think like if
you want to achieve that six-pack look
then because you're wearing it around
your waist um you're sweating more in
that area so psychologically it feels
like you're targeting this yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's the same thing with the
face brought to it I was watching some
videos and some girls were wearing it
and there it took it off really I'm so
sweaty
I lost centimeters off you can't even
measure a centimeter really too small
yeah I don't know what that is how do
you even measure yeah do they have like
one of those comes with its own like
measuring table like the property do
they metaphor my jaw just the bone
structure I go down from there yeah from
here to here that does look like that
tool I'm more interested like about the
person who sees this and goes you know
this is it like this works that's it
that's more fascinating to me than the
people who made it are like this this is
a jobber and make some money off this
the people who like do it hey man if it
makes you feel better at the end of the
day like if you wore it and you like now
appear to look
better in the mirror then it worked and
if you like it then cool it worked for
you it works love your head back yeah
but she also didn't explain that she's
been running two miles or maybe she's
happier look she's smiling she's less
makeup dude it's working
I want to see everyone what's it like I
trust this to not be Photoshop yeah they
never look at how much happier she is
her hair's better she was like as long
as you're happy at the end of the day
but it's like it's not if it's not
really working you're not going to be
happier than today you're gonna be
spending actually yeah you'll go back to
happiness yeah you're just gonna be
getting more frustrated and spending
money on things that don't work when
you're like you could be doing the right
thing and then actually being well the
right thing is never the fun thing
it never is I remember my favorite piece
of work my first piece of workout
equipment was the grip team you guys are
traveling oh yeah oh yeah and as a kid
I'll be like that couldn't even grip it
my right one I was able to get like
three reps and I put my left hand like I
just end up training just all in my
supposed to jack off more of their left
hands and then they could not even know
what Jack cough was he was using poles
we might have found a copy we're doing
this before you were jerking off man you
were you were full fitness yeah I found
it when I was like five or something
just laying around the house and I did
like random things in the house I have
to do two hands and shoot when I was
like so we're still talking about the
maybe had a weak-ass one now we just
talked
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]